Ballroom like this altitude I can run
flat out for a half-mile before my hands
start shaking
come on super quick now I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this podcast is brought to
you by 4 Sigma tech I reached out to
these Finnish folks young entrepreneurs
very talented after a Acrobat introduced
me to one of their products which is
mushroom coffee this specific one
includes chaga and lion's mane and nut
my socks off I highly recommend if you
try it you start with half a packet it's
very strong and lights you up like a
Christmas tree in the best way possible
people are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer I try to force
this on all of my houseguests it is a
hell of a thing if I have employees or
people come over who are working on
projects with me I always try to feed it
to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect it's a lot more out of
them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
their products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this and the
coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner of my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's four sig Matic
fo you are SI g ma TI c calm forward
slash Tim and use the code Tim
I am to get 20% off of your first order
and they're not that expensive anyway if
you are in the experimental mindset I do
not think you'll be disappointed to try
them up this episode is brought to you
by audible which I've used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you will thank me there are
a few different versions
I like the version that Neal narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Ralph Hawks
Pio tts which had a huge impact on my
life and form the basis for a lot of
what would later become the 4-hour
workweek so go to audible.com for word
slash Tim and you can choose one of
these two books or any of many many
other options that could be books
magazines and much more as a listener of
the Tim Ferriss show you can also access
a free 30-day trial just go to
audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at audible.com forward slash
Tim to start now and get your free
30-day trial
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show I'm sitting in a cabin
surrounded by snow and it is still my
job every episode to deconstruct
world-class performers of all different
types from entertainment to military
chess to jujitsu you name it I have
tried to interview the best of the best
in that world and in this particular
episode we are going to talk about
anti-aging what does that mean well
there's a lot of hogwash eleven nonsense
out there but there are a few people who
really stand out as particularly
interesting because they walk the talk
dr. Arthur Devaney is nearly 80 years
old and totally ripped I just spent a
bunch of time with him better known as
art devaney and you should check him out
on Facebook facebook.com forward slash
art dot Devaney de va and why he was
signed as a professional baseball player
in his youth and later earned his PhD
economics at UCLA he is most famous for
his evolutionary fitness that's the term
you'd use approach to training and diet
in our conversation focuses a lot on the
subtleties and details of that during
his time at UCLA art did many things
including creating mathematical and
statistical models to precisely describe
the motion picture market R is now
professor emeritus of economics of
University of California Irvine is a
member of their acclaimed Institute for
mathematical behavioral sciences so this
guy is very analytical he's very
mathematical and very very logical and
that is the water on the kettle but I'm
going to power through it because I'm
going to have tea but it's going to be
after this intro is recorded a lifelong
student of metabolism and fitness art
has lived as a paleo athlete for more
than 30 years and is considered a
patriarch of the paleo movement right up
there with Loren Cordain he believes
there's no such thing as healthy aging
and that we can intervene to protect
against the aging process and in this
episode we talk about his daily schedule
workout routines
Nassim Taleb why he never gets sick that
is why art never gets sick and really
dig into the details of a fascinating
man there's also one point where I doubt
myself which happens fairly often and I
mentioned myotatic reflex and then I
renege and say I don't know what I'm
talking
about so just to explain what I meant by
that here's the definition the stretch
reflex also known as myotatic reflex is
from wikipedia is a muscle contraction
response to stretching within the muscle
it is a monosynaptic reflex which
provides automatic regulation of
skeletal muscle like on a muscle
lengthens the muscle spindle is
stretched and it's nerve activity
increases that sounds like gobbledygook
to a lot of you but that is why I said
my akattak reflexes it's related to
doing negative only or negative dominant
workouts which arc arc art subscribes to
alright so there you have it there's a
lot of dense stuff in here we get into
the weeds which you guys love but if
you're having trouble grasping something
and it's getting very dense just hold on
and listen for a few more minutes and
we'll get back into more familiar
territory we talk about everything from
ice ages to economics to the
philosophies of intermittent everything
we talk about the extreme events and the
economics thereof it's a fascinating
conversation at least it was for me so
without further ado as I always say I'm
going to go get my tea now please enjoy
this conversation with art Devaney art
welcome to the show happy to be here Tim
I am thrilled to meet you I've heard so
much about you for many people including
our mutual friend
Duvall Rebecca and we're sitting here
for those people listening at my
undisclosed Mountain location and art
was kind enough to meet me here and here
we are at the kitchen table and I
thought we would just start with how you
connected with Duvall because I don't
know the story I started with my blog he
got in touch with me and I decided to
give a seminar in Las Vegas
covering sort of the elements of my
approach and he and his brother Kamal
attended along Ridge with John Durant
sure and Richard Nicolay and then a
whole bunch of other people who've gone
on to fame and fortune in the paleo
world and you've kept in in contact with
navall or at least he is certainly very
familiar with with the blog
if we were winding the clock a little
bit how did you go well actually I'll
take a step back I was going to ask you
how you went from economics to the
evolutionary approach to everything but
before I go there how did you get the
economics oh yeah well I loved economics
it's a study of decentralized mechanisms
and organizations and spontaneous order
I got into it because I took a
undergraduate class in comparative
economic systems at UCLA and I had a
professor who was just profoundly
inspiring in that class George Murphy
and give him credit it may he may
disclaim my credit but he he was so
eloquent in talking about Hayek and oh
god I'm Ranko Baroni and a whole bunch
of other people who wrestled with
central planning it's a time when
central planning was sweeping Europe and
as being promoted even in the United
States the progressive movement at that
time if they felt this centralized
control scientific management top-down
hierarchical control would be the the
sensible way to do in fact I wrote a
book about the Inland Waterways that
criticized that approach and talked
about how they actually messed up the
flood plains and they thought there was
a hundred year flood plain but floods
don't have mean statistics they don't
converge they diverge so the variance
keeps growing with every new flood what
is that for people who don't have any
familiar with familiarity with economics
what is that what does that mean I think
it may be elaborate on that well the
very answer course is a merit measure of
the variation in the series of the
series if it hasn't mean you know most
people think in terms of normal
distributions that has central
tendencies and that the mean and
variation are well described by those
two parameters not true the damage
it's done by the worst rainstorm at a
decade does 40% of all the damage that
rain storms do in that decade this is
it's a it's an extreme event dominated
series just like the movies and just
like your life people fail to realize
you know you don't get anywhere from the
drip drip drip of the incremental you
get there from some big event that
changes your life like your book
probably change your life I don't know
what changed my life lots of things jail
but those are the moments that are the
power moments in your life and in fact
the whole notion of normal doesn't apply
to a person's life
you know you don't get anywhere by
incrementing in small increments it's
the extreme event and you sees it in
your poise if you remain poised you can
respond to that kind of significant
event for example there's this notion of
algorithmic compressibility which is the
computer science term that applies to
the ability to reduce your life to an
algorithm can't do it can't do it if a
novelty in your life is constantly
progressing and you should welcome the
variants seize the opportunities oh that
was that that's the way I think of life
and it's lizanne of evolutionary fitness
that that's how that's how life works
out so we're going to spend the majority
I think of our conversation on
evolutionary fitness and I have so many
questions for you but I want to start
with an area I know even less about
which is Hollywood yeah so what are some
of the erroneous beliefs or these that
you found in Hollywood or insights that
that you've written about and unstudied
well you know it's an industry that
nobody understands nobody's really
written anything very sensible about the
industry the Supreme Court for example
divorced the studios from the theaters
and justice Douglas was a guy who wrote
the decision the firmest paramount
antitrust decrees it treated the
industry is a monopoly because they
looked at market shares which if you
measure at a particular point in time
paramount will have so many dollars of
the total greven of the industry
Universal will have so many and on down
the line problem is that changes every
week so if you use something like a
hurtin dollar index or measure of
concentration it's constantly varying in
fact it has no mean it's the second
moment that excuse me miss the second
it's the variance of the distribution of
market shares the Herpen dollar index is
and it's in
it doesn't exist Mall info wrote about
this
so did oh who is the other guy who did
fractals anyway it doesn't matter who
the oh the Mandelbrot yeah yeah mantle
bro he coined the word fractal because
it it's a situation where the variation
is so extreme that the distribution
itself doesn't have the normal kinds of
limits it's a so-called wild
distribution as nothing to lab calls
them and these wild distributions don't
have finite moments necessarily the
meaning variance may not exist but such
as in the flood example and that's true
also in the movies turned out that the
movies has such a wild distribution that
even the mean doesn't exist so if you
talk about the average gross you're
talking about no movie that ever made
that there reminds me of there's a some
type of joke it was meant to illustrate
the flaw in how people miss apply an
arithmetic mean and so you know Bill
Gates walks into a bar and suddenly the
the average net worth is fifty million
dollars or something like that
Bill Gates walks in the bar and
everybody's a millionaire on average
okay yeah that's exactly yeah so does
this make movies impossible to predict
or plan for how would you build that and
if you ran a studio
how would that inform what you've
learned how that informed decisions that
you make well you've got to have a story
and characters the audience will love as
remember cally curry she invited me to
come speak to this screen actor the
screenwriters killed and she said you
make a movie but you make the audience
love the characters and then you torture
them search of the characters yeah so I
guess and any would be visa via the
characters the audience sort or to the
characters right so the idea is that you
a great script a great story memorable
characters
then the rest is up to the audience it
may or may not work on an actor because
the same kind of variance in his career
grosses as does the industry in general
so the an accurate weight would make one
movie in that movie will earn 40 percent
of the actor's career revenues same
thing with directors if you if you did
all the regressions in the world there's
a statistical technique for trying to
predict what a movie's going to make you
would find out that a handful of actors
have any significance and they're sort
of Luke's anyway like Val Kilmer killed
killer came up in back in the regression
equations he's going now I mean it's
it's not that the past doesn't predict
the future is really the way to look at
it and there's no how grilling to to
determine how a movie is going to gross
genre is somewhat helpful but only
because people look at John regenerate
is not a category is something that
people put it's a box people put put
movies in you really want to know how
much a movie is going to make you have
to look at how many theaters they open
it on its the cereal box in fact if you
go into a grocery store and Wheaties
gets all the shelf space except for a
few share inches it's going to have the
highest gross it might disappear very
quickly though because of a big opening
is a dangerous strategy it tends to give
you dominant revenues in the early weeks
and if people follow the revenues as a
means of making a decision how to go
which movie to go to that would tend to
propel in a dynamic where you would have
an expansive growth problem is you also
have word-of-mouth and reviews so it's a
it's a mixture public and private
information private information being
with your friends tell you about it
public information being reading your
box office scores you put those two
together and you just have an enormously
complicated dynamics you
you can't tell how it's going to do
asthma is matter if it if if you don't
get the grosses and you have four
thousand theaters committed their
screens to your movie you may have to
love them to double bill in the second
week that is add another feature to it
oh if you see a movie that's still
building by the third week it's a
stinker so I and yeah I would I would
imagine it's similar books to my
meanness wasn't any hits driven business
there are some people who try to
front-load with distribution so they
have this huge initial upfront cost in
the hopes that it will make the list
somewhere at the top and then become a a
self-fulfilling cycle of sorts where
people use it as a shop it's the same
kind of thing and actually a lot of
authors would go out and buy lots of
copies of your book oh yeah I know I
know people have bought you know I
remember I visited as you'll not name
names but I went to the the office the
headquarters of a CEO who had recently
published his own book before I should
say had his book published which he did
not write and there were tens of
thousands of copies gliding along it was
just outrageous he could have built an
entire structure out of these book well
the public has - they're smart they've
learned that it if you just look at the
sales itself that's what a lot of other
people are doing but it could be that
they're manipulating the sales as a way
of signaling to you that it's a it's a
great book so you look at reviews and
you see what the authors done before it
might work if you're Tom Hanks in a
movie but then again it could be he said
he has huge variance in his grosses also
he's not a sure thing yeah what a star
will do is it will
raised the least revenue a film lighter
I see it raises the minimum revenue and
then because it gets to that level a
fair number screens and some people will
come but then we're Emmaus starts to
take over and it can it can tank in no
time so you developed these these mental
models this analytical these analytical
frameworks
how did fitness and diet enter the scene
for you and or how did that how did you
start focusing on that it really Bank
began the other way around I always
wanted to be fit and strong and have a
beautiful body and healthy-looking skin
and so forth there's just like people
liking me and looking there being so ego
helps a lot in this game yeah but I also
was interested in in Fitness and eating
well most of my life however that meant
that blended with that plus my interest
in athletics and I wanted to be a pro
baseball player eyesight let me down so
those that that mixture led me to
appreciate the hunter-gatherer kind of
lifestyle that is if you if you view
uncertainty in the world the way I do
and you realize you we came through a
narrow bottleneck only 2500 or so humans
made it through the Toba the post Toba
volcanic eruption the volcanic winter
there was the lowest temperature and
then in the last 20,000 years was post
Toba and so we came through a bottleneck
like that you realize that we have to be
extremely Hardy very robust you had to
be poised the brain is there in order to
adapt to the climate variations that the
humans went through there were there
were 20,000 years of extreme climate
variation and a good brain is a good way
to
get through that sort of thing you can
imagine God's designers human designers
saying well we've got a new kind of we
got a new model now it's different from
the archaic model in the sense it has a
very large brain it's smart as hell this
kind of fad slow and God just says well
let's see if it gets to the Ice Age is a
high of twenty thousand years of ice
ages plans ahead of it and that's what
happened the archaic form didn't last
and all the other closely related forms
of human beings disappeared at this time
during the and earth all the Homo
heidelbergensis of other even home Homo
erectus was still around early on in
this period two thousand two hundred
thousand years ago so they all
disappeared and they all disappeared
because he didn't have
the adaptive behavior that the modern
humans have said brain was a survival
instrument that means that we're here we
have a great brain simply because it
it's a way of adapting to the challenges
that the borough presents to us and you
couldn't have the brain that we have
unless you had a body as well the brain
body brain muscle signaling is dominates
most of my thinking so a fit of an
approach to fitness it think of the sea
squirt I'll admit I don't know much
about sea squirts and sea squirts a
little polyp that lives in the sea and
it floats around finds a location
latches on to that Barcalounger and eats
a spring eats its own brain eats its own
brain because it's found his place it no
longer needs to navigate the world and
the brain is dispensable and every bit
of protein and substrate that the animal
could get ahold of of course it's going
to eat so at that point the sea squirt
consumes a spring a lot of people hear
that too don't think yes because I think
a lot of that happening right now yeah
yeah settling into a couch you lose your
you lose your muscle your brain begins
to degenerate because it's not getting
the signals that the muscles muscles
release all kinds of so-called Maya
kinds now that had been discovered and
it also a remote signal from the muscle
can cause your brain to improve its cell
quality to maintain neurons one thing
you could do is to contract muscles and
you'll find you may improve what's
called Prairie or stasis in them in the
neurons predator stasis is maintaining
the cellular quality not having miss
folded proteins misshapen proteins wrong
kind of protein Jr is that related to a
like a brain derived neurotrophic factor
or things like that or is it a second it
also does that but see no chopping
factors are typically growth type
factors that rescue stressed cell and
that does happen but the other part of
it is that you need to alter insulin
signaling so that you're actually
bring on the defensive pathways in that
neuron as opposed to the growth right
the growth factors in signal growth same
way so that would bring on foxo and
sirtuins and other factors in the neuron
so that kind of signaling and if you if
you affect Proteus tatius in the brain
the brain then can send neural signals
to effect produce cases in remote
tissues now we're into this motion
remote signaling or signaling at a
distance which is systemic signaling
economists love that kind of an you know
the kind of model that an adaptive kind
of decentralized behavior and what what
types of if we're looking at so for
instance I was
listen to one of your presentations and
one of the unwanted slides I just wrote
down two lines and it was it reads aging
is not programmed that as a result of
the failure of a renewal program all
right and I would love to hear you a
elaborate on that maybe a little bit and
then be follow that through with the
implications in terms of behaviors that
might help or diet anything that might
help you bolster that renewal system and
well you know aging is really a puzzle I
only started studying it a few years ago
and I figured well I'm an expert because
I'm experienced I was about 78 years old
when I started looking at at aging and
as I thought it really is a lot simpler
than people are making it out to be
it is not programmed there there's no no
aging genes have been discovered the
only change that have been discovered to
have any bearing on aging or defensive
pathways FOXO sirtuins proto stasis a
host of other defensive immunity
stem cell proliferation they're four or
five pathways that are involved in aging
and in the main they are regenerative or
defensive pathways like immunity the
immune pathways cross over with your
cell maintenance that defensive pathways
for example etapa G is used in both
processes at otha G being the the
consumption of self tissues of own
tissues they say G being eating and also
being you your own tissues so tough
topic to use both an element of the
immune system it's also an element of
keeping the stem cells alive and healthy
because they're living on a toffee G and
when they when they need to proliferate
and come out and heal wound your tissues
they go through a burst of etapa g and
then they transition into
into oxygen phosphorus they use
oxidation pathways after that
very in there being defended by ontology
so that the mitochondria don't damage
the stem cells they have to live in a
low oxygen niche picked a very similar
to a very primitive form of cell it they
live on basically glycolysis and if that
was all life lived at one time and
you're fast twitch muscle fibers also
abused the most primitive kind of energy
sources for for movement so the
defensive pathways are really the key to
it all and the appearance the poets know
this the legend of to thanas is a legend
of the Greek god of all rose he was a
roars boyfriend and Zeus didn't like it
so Aurora pleaded with him with with
Zeus not to kill him so Zeus in his
clever way said well ok you're going to
live forever but he didn't he forgot to
say I'm not going to let you age so to
phonus waste away for eternity as a
cruel punishment but it's a correct
description of what the aging process is
the loss of self function loss of cell
integrity a loss of the ability of stem
cells to renew tissues so aging
basically is simply damaged what are
some of the interventions that that you
find most interesting at this point I
eat only twice a day so I long I want
long intervals between meals
I want low insulin signaling so that I
bring on the defensive and repair
pathways I want to be conscious of
maintaining my stem cells now how do you
maintain your stem cells well first of
all you don't have too much mitochondria
with instant down in your stem cells so
I yeah what I really want to talk about
this ok
mitochondrial densities all the range
all right I didn't see it it seems to be
all the rage isn't it and like their
innocent little batteries that just
sacrifice and produce energy for it
remember they have their own DNA
so mitochondria density has to be very
low in the stem cell issues
moreover with mitochondrial
activity level for example humans people
don't know that humans have the lowest
mitochondria density of any mammal
really yes and they also have low low
reactive type of mitochondria Alice
Riall King wealth out of the l3
mitochondrial haplotype that left Africa
number mitochondrion Eve occurred about
sixteen hundred thirty eight thousand
years ago by that time humans were
huddled on the seashore in South Africa
trying to survive the temperature was so
cold and so much ice was locked up
moisture that the Sahara expanded in
scope and became very arid so after
after Toba a volcanic eruption the
largest volcanic eruption in the last
two million years humans were basically
settled in long being the southern and
eastern shore of Africa huddled there to
survive and by Curtis Marion thinks that
the the seashore saved humanity the UH
the accessibility of sea sea food along
them the shore vegetables were wiped out
for about a thousand years or not there
was a thousand-year volcanic winter and
vegetables were difficult to come by and
the inland sources of animals were
response as well it turns out we may
have survived on corms they're a starchy
plant it is in the biome of South
southern Africa corbs
corpse I'll see you on M s yes I've seen
this written yeah arms it's a
carbohydrate-containing I had just tell
the tale you guys this between the
muscles and then the washed up seals and
an occasional beached whale and the sea
birds and occasionally in land hunting
that that's basically how we survive
mussels mussels are your friend and both
both kinds of mussels
so so there's the survival aspect the
dhaa of course in a thief who became a
substrate for them for the brain and you
can see the remarkable photos that show
the difference between it's a hundred
thousand years difference in the human
skull it's a profound difference you can
see that the human skull the modern
humans golden emerge is kind of a
analyzed version of the earlier skull
and the high prefrontal area of the
cortex and what-have-you so bringing
expansion clearly occurred in response
to two things the availability nutrition
to help propel brain growth
the need to have high brain cognitive
power to survive the ice ages plus the
growing settlement size on the seashore
because we now had a stable source of of
food we I'm thinking of us you know
coming from that period and that debt
spurred technology and remember language
developed at this time too so it was a
enormous change in human behavior during
this time period and so we were talking
about the interventions you mentioned
eating two times a day and we'll come
back to this I think but is that
generally breakfast dinner lunch dinner
what's the what does your split look
like well whatever suits you but I do
lunch I do I do breakfast dinner because
I want a long interval between meals to
promote produce daesh's I want I want to
clear the enzymes I want to remember
you've got there about a billions
proteins in a Cell according to Dillon's
group up at Berkeley Oh Berkeley and
it's very critical to the the
degradation of the proteins is sort of a
continuous process once the
transcription and making new proteins is
interval based kind of thing it depends
on when the nutrient signals are there
when when when mTOR begins to say okay
don't consume proteins make new ones
transcribe and translate although when
you transfer carbon translate you find
that that moves up a diagonal that's it
the atrophy process follows it
because you've got to keep some kind of
balance there over my theory is this
that we we had to overeat in order to
survive we don't live on energy balance
and if you look at this as a random
world you can't survive unless you
overeat during periods when food is
available so as to store of nutrients
for the times of scarcity we also over
proliferate that is when nutrients are
available the transcription and
translation process turns on in sort of
a bursts has to be because otherwise you
won't make an appropriate sister five
year cells won't be durable that is
what's killing us today because we're
over transcribing already we're making
too many proteins to get miss folded
damaged they don't there's no room for
them the architecture the cell is
stretched the actin filaments are
stretched down and there's stress
signaling going on and you don't
transcribe accurately you don't make
good proteins when you're under stress
we also talked then about the low
mitochondrial density here stem cell
niches as I said yeah they reside in a
low oxygen niche so how do you how do
you proactively encourage low
mitochondrial density in those areas you
do weightlifting you stay off the
treadmill actually if if you sprint you
can use up you can consume mitochondria
because you improve mitochondria then
quality I got it so they become more
sort of effective and efficient so they
don't need you need the density that's
right that's right and and they or not
is they don't realize much on oxidation
either you're using the glycolytic
pathway which goes through the
mitochondria anyway within the Krebs
cycle and so forth but it's not it's not
producing lots of free radicals are you
responsible for getting a nothing column
deadlifting is that my fault
well you remember the story about
nothing might have you if you read the
back section of their little section you
wrote from my book because he here he
was a kurtosis traitor
that is he used distributions with wild
characteristics he was he was buying out
of the money calls and puts and living
on the barians bright he was a bag worth
living in the options room yes that's
right and so here he was doing just
steady state exercise and I said what
what what are you doing this is the
wrong approach just I just so I know
because I and how did you first
I did the two of you connect I used his
book in a class I taught fooled by
randomness I used in a class I taught on
the economics of uncertainty I told him
I communicated with him I said I'm using
your book I don't want rhodium but I
because I hate textbooks and I really
connected with him he said no he hates
textbooks sure you really yeah you
really hit a it's like Soros five you
could get him started on a cat academia
so it she connected with him and then he
was doing steady state exercise it was
he was doing his you know three sets of
twelve and so many hours on the twig
treadmill or the the cycling or whatever
and he figured out that in cycling to
and from his office that's when he his
office was some distance from his and
Jim he said he figured out that the
maximum expenditure of energy and that
ride was within of the most good and
that's that's your approach to has four
hours for example in an organization the
meeting the half the work is done by the
square root of n workers so you got a
hundred people in there Ken workers
produce half the other which can that
mean this is run the same page with this
inclusive Pareto distribution yet right
and this is just a little prices work
and Latka and others have looked at
scientific publish
have you the Pope is his own own version
of this by the way ho John Pope John
Paul before before he passed away he was
asked how many people work at the
Vatican he said about half of them are a
curse Robert Evans says the same thing
about Hollywood Hollywood the place
where half the people are not working
and it's true between films and I hope
you've been an exponent so even Dustin
Hoffman is great he said I have to be
grateful to be working uh this goes with
the business that in the industry there
are these power law distributed networks
and a few people are at the symbol hubs
and so it's the same holds for the movie
industry probably half the people do
about 10% of the people do about half
half the movies or something like that
it's enough the same thought that the
the calorie expenditure during his bike
ride was what was given him the most
bang for the buck and you imagine the
people for that dumb back in those days
and there's still people around who
think that is an energy balance model I
don't know how well let's face it they
all studied steady state exercise
because you put someone on the treadmill
and you measured Assad regime
expenditure nobody had any idea
non-steady state exercising very
difficult to quantifying the measure now
they're getting better at it much better
the power law holds again because the
most intense exercise the most intense
expenditures to the ball
you put accelerometers on children the
leanest are the ones who engage in the
most intense purse a little little
children don't steady theta exercise so
what does your exercise regimen look
like or what you would prescribe to
someone like a Nassim or anyone really
well I told that seemed to start doing
negative deadlifts if he wants to
improve his deadlifts
have somebody help to put the bar up
lower it could pick a height and then
put it up again and lower it again and
put it up Lord again I do I do almost
all negatives now why is that you talk
about why why wiring eccentric
well so what I'm doing eccentrics for
really three reasons the main one being
that they double your stem cell counts
and then the satellite cells in the
muscle now the double nun but they don't
exhaust them a lot of people if you
double the stem cells it flood out you
may exhaust them because you made simply
exhaust in the ones in the niche what
you want to do is you want to double
them and have one go back into the
nation one go out sin and heal tissues
asymmetric differentiation is when you
want if they symmetrically differentiate
they both become new possible
progenitors to themselves
you're now exhausting put what take one
out put one in it is the best way to do
it and eccentric exercise does set
downhill running judge to downhill
running down here I mean how do you in
said I'd love to hear what a way a
negative focused workout of yours might
look like and if you could also just
talk about mitigating injury risk yeah
because that there are a lot of people
who get in for instance there are a lot
of sprinters who in their training will
only do the positive on deadlifts and
drop them for fear of hamstring injuries
so not to say it can't be done safely
because I've done a lot of natives but
I'd love to hear what a workout of yours
looks like it's so mild you wouldn't
believe it I work off on almost every
day ok maybe 10-15 minutes and sometimes
it's hard to do it negative if you don't
have a training partner but I use
equipment and I'll use like for example
leg extensions
Chhotu loan of one yeah typical lake
press push up a to lower with one on
solder press push up with two actually I
use I use a machine Anastasia they're
like the power hammer stuff I'll push it
up to an Lord with one and don't wait
you're all fast which I'm mostly from
fast twitch fibers so they really
respond well well to that on what body
just since you mentioned it which muscle
groups respond best to this type of
training all of them all of them like
Astro muscles you they're slow twitch
fibers you need to stay V to have
endurance keep your posture locked in is
so I end every workout standing against
the wall none this was the thing that
involved like most about my seminar
stand against the wall you know get get
a little slot in the smaller your back
put your heels and butt against the wall
your shoulders back your head back walk
off and leave look over your cheek bones
don't look don't drop your head and
start looking down your whole spine
collapses so look straight at weight if
you need to look down just look down
over your cheekbone I said don't drop
don't drop your head you intersect your
head and rest assure so this is to
establish proper posture it is to
establish proper posture but also
to taint it and to have a sort of
nobility having good posture it really
makes a difference in your mental
amateur are you working your entire body
every your entire body every day no I'm
not because I may want to I might do
legs and shoulders one day and I might
do almost never do girls because they're
just ego muscles anyway but I'm just
going around and do a variety of
exercises I make sure to hit everybody a
couple times a week and I'm cycling
through and I do a lot of lat and lower
back and leg work and children work when
you in sees at 10 to 15 minutes how do
you choose let's just take an example in
the shoulder press how are you
determining what weight to use is a
percentage of say one rep concentric and
then what is the the temple number of
repetitions if you just give us an idea
of the programming of that I'm such an
instinctive trading and what training
like Arnold is yeah um I might just
don't have a regular way I just do it
okay you go to the point where you start
to lose the ability to control the
descent or when do you terminate a speed
I do I have some sense of fatigue but
what I do is I push it up really fast
and quickly in a very precise form but
very lots of acceleration and then
coming down really slow and it took full
good stretch you have to remember have
this giant protein in your muscles is
tighten the protein it's the stress
sensor and stressed by the way will
stimulate mTOR in protein synthesis the
stretch yes that's the is that and I
might be getting this run my o tatak
reflects my getting ass and i i don't
know i'm talking about please continue
yeah i want a well there's a certainly
domain down in the and tighten protein
passes it sets the architecture of the
home muscle really that and the action
if there's there's a cytoskeleton a
skeleton in the muscle itself of these
actin fibers
and if there's threats and sin if they
send stretching you the dystrophin
protein to certain senses the distortion
of the enclosure to the muscle and then
the tighten senses the extension of the
muscle that means you want to really go
to a full stretch if your interests if
you did curls and never fully stretched
you would you have a little tiny muscle
you've got to stretch the muscle out and
Goldbergs work and all that all kinds of
work on muscle shows that full extension
you lengthen the muscle to lengthen
muscle is stronger and fuller when it's
contracted and it's faster so I go a lot
of my muscles to be not too big
lean well and quick what a from a
distant evolutionary standpoint what
would have mimicked the Centrex
aside from downhill running well
actually any kind of running does it as
you know because every impact is
eccentric right stress any kind of
lowering on Mars if you had a lift and
lower things here
I suppose carry even carrying is a
certain degree of eccentric exercise but
I only see this is this is stone-age
plus high tech right and the high tech
part of is looked at Macaluso work on
stem cell activation others other work
on it as well I wanted efficient time
time efficient exercise keep me injury
free and injury free is really very
important than how almost no interest in
the gym over sixty years of using using
gym so I can think of one one one injury
so your efficient
injury-free the fast which type of
fibers are the ones who are hitting when
you do descending when you get older
your motor neurons aren't as effective
so you want to have the kind of heavy
stimulation of the fast which fibers
they're the ones that have the biggest
motor neurons and the way to do that is
negatives like that they're just very
safe very effective of course you can't
do negatives on everything cuz you know
it's awkward and right what have you so
you can you can at least concentrate on
accelerating smoothly and rapidly up and
then descending slowly I mean Doug
macguff flexes sort of stuff and there's
probably the best thing about his
exercise is the slow descent yeah yeah
but I would never work out hard enough
or I have to rest the whole week I do
something every day what's the what's
the rationale behind behind that as
opposed to having longer rest intervals
okay well I want a renewal signal every
day the renewal signal is one its
fasting before exercise then the fasted
when do you workout typically when do
you do this 15 - a workout at 11 o'clock
in the morning typically so keep got it
so yeah I'll get up like 7 or 6 and I'll
have a mild breakfast to the like 8 what
would be would be some of your default
breakfasts well my favorite default let
breakfast is a giant smoked turkey lake
with a little bit of melon uh they're
very inexpensive and they're fun to eat
[Laughter]
sounds fantastic I wish I had some of
that here especially you guys - two big
turkey legs to package it had Walmart
even and I wanted one turkey leg and
maybe have sort of a melon got it and
then I will work out at 11:00 I'll have
a 15 20 minute workouts because I like
to go around any girls there get to it
while I'm there
and uh I won't eat until four hours
after they like it five o'clock got it
so that's your that's your evening meal
and then you don't eat it between 5:00
and when do you typically go to sleep I
might go to bed at 11:00
okay all right no but so you'd finish
your last meal by say six o'clock and
they don't have four or five hours of
fasting before bed
that's correct got it okay all right I
won't tell you know maybe even lunch the
next day just depends
hmm got it I I never have three meals a
day as sometimes have one sometimes none
most times - but you don't have to cut
calories it's just the timing it's the
intervals between meals where you have
low insulin sense signaling high atop
the G and Proteus tatius mechanism like
the proteasome is eating up enzymes soon
you're clearing the damage your your
tapas you peaks at about four hours
after four to six hours after exercise
all these guys who who does already
after their work out they're killing
you're killing the adaptive process you
can't have without a proper atopic you
your muscles to generate you have to
clear the old damaged proteins and
that's how you do it
the proteasome is that little core shape
barrel shaped object in the in the cell
that that consumes mostly enzymes that
have done their job clears enzymes if
you have enzymes to stay there too long
or are our neural factors of some kind
like Coleco stress hormones you have to
eat those up there the whole thing is
dynamic protein generation and clearance
so what I'm doing is I'm working out I'm
stimulating the topic view process and
the Proteus aces Proteus aces of protein
quality maintenance process so five four
hours later that's that's peak it's over
and I'm good and hungry I have a nice
big meal what does dinner look like
we'll be set an example of a dinner that
you enjoy but I have my wife hands me
something usually it's so I usually do
all my own cooking Wayne went after my
first wife passed away but now she is
such a great cook I would have a big
mound of spinach with lots of garlic in
it and there maybe she makes a lot of
pot roast her own way though is one an
Italian way of course a fair amount of
steak I'll have an occasional prime rib
but I always cut the excess fat I don't
like fatty beets is that just a personal
preference or is there a sort of thought
there scientific reason behind are just
palate because both it's both personal I
trust my taste and if something is just
like oh this is too much of this back
off in the other part of it is if if you
want to have a fatty liver you eat a lot
of fat like there's no way around it got
it yeah you know you oxidize
energy sources according to how easy the
Ardex oxidize so first carbohydrate goes
and maybe protein or fat the fat still
has to go so has to go somewhere
and excess adipose tissues one of the
worst things you can do about
accountants is so crucial and if you get
if your liver starts filling up with
that this is that where it shouldn't be
this is like ectopic fat and a bill then
is also building up in your bone marrow
in your muscle in your thymus you know
in your brain so the fatty degeneration
is a source of stem cell just
differentiation Sam stem cell will come
wandering out and say I'm going to fix
this muscle but it encounters a lot of
fat in the muscle so it differentiates
you out of the site instead of muscles
remember these stem cells are very
plastic they can take on a fate
depending on the tissue you arrived you
and what signals they receive their
local it's local as well as the global
signals that are causing that sea body
bill is always Newt was volume that
built mass I think this is really
generally true lots and lots of buying
even to workouts today these I was
around a lot of these guys sure I get
the volume in a different way I work out
every day but maybe twenty minutes at
the most
right I do think one thing don't work
out at all what do some people in the
paleo movement get wrong what do you
think of the most common errors or
logical fallacies or damaging fads or
trends that you observe and people who
self identify as paleo
very interesting because there are there
are a lot of little tribes inside the
ocean a lot of faction and I don't
frankly I don't keep track of these guys
are just too many people trying to say
too many things they eat too much fat
mm-hmm absolutely true they a lot of
them went off while while we into the
into fat consumption so they probably
have fatty livers by now I really I mean
you cannot eat large amounts of fat and
not have a family Lerner
you can't who needs all the energy
they're trying to they're worried about
energy balance why don't you worry about
energy to that balance do you they think
they think there are particular kinds of
foods they have to eat but really
variety in flavor texture color that's
that's how you choose your meals what
are your thoughts on I love your
Facebook page by the way I do have
questions about why you got rid of your
blog but I your Facebook has four sort
of information density then I've seen in
almost any other Facebook page and what
are your thoughts on coconut oil and
coconut products
I wouldn't do it you wouldn't do it now
does that come back to the fatty liver
and just a percentage of your total
intake as as fat well first of all it's
it's an evolutionary non sequitur
doesn't follow you would not be seeing
large amounts of coconut consumption in
the Paleolithic so it that it's just odd
first of all and it's kind of a fad
second of all and there who knows of the
manufactures of these things are all
signs of impurities that are involved um
it doesn't taste good either anybody I
don't like you you gal I'll confess I'm
pretty sick oh come on ten million has
got so much fat in it already why would
you ever need to have any additional
sources of fat and they even is olive
oil I'm sparing with do cook eggs or do
you consume eggs sure you do how do you
prepare your eggs
fried boiled scramble so if you if you
fry them what are you using to frying or
scrambled what are you using a small
amount of olive oil using butter or
using small amount olive oil in a
moderate temperature and I don't know
actually haven't seen my wife cooking
the eggs lately I don't know how she
does boil free would be perfectly fine
with me if you had a pan did you know
he's one of these ceramic pans that
would think slide off
she never burns an egg either they're
always wonderfully done I used to throw
a yoke away when I eat four boiled eggs
you know would do you would you still do
that if you're consuming eggs
I find the yolk bit odd in taste and I
don't like too much yolk but I don't
throw but I get tired very tired very
quickly got it yeah I found I love eggs
but I only recently discovered a few
years ago and it's so simple how to make
proper soft-boiled eggs so you have a
nice delicious yolk as opposed to the
yellow golf ball the hard-boiled
she's just so chunky and unpleasant yes
yes later let's talk a little bit about
you mentioned the consumption of say
post-workout carbohydrates and amino
acids or whatever it might be look to
chat a little bit about mTOR so this is
you know this is a big subject and a lot
of people are trying to minimize mTOR
activation and leak in the hope of
extending lifespan and health span you
know and so a general hear your thoughts
on on that where people are si doing
everything they can to minimize
activation event or they're trying to
remove that leucine they're trying to
get their igf-1 as low as possible
so thoughts in general and emptor and
then also on the use of say rapamycin or
metformin but look when I alter
proliferation or hyper proliferation is
considered to be one of the evils of
modern world but it was a necessary
adaptation in the past you couldn't have
survived if you prefer a rapidly in the
presence food because you wouldn't
haven't had a chance later on had it be
very effective at doing that but there
would have been in the evolutionary
times there would have been a protein
quality control process following that
because you've had a fairly long
interval without food so overdriving
mTOR was never a problem they're talking
in the modern world about people who
never shut him door off basically if you
don't have these intervals between meals
and you're over driving mTOR so you're
creating lots of misfolded proteins
Proteus stasis is collapsing the first
thing is C elegans does when it starts
to die as his protege of stasis
collapses ceilings as our favorite worm
yes for Africa huh so you don't want
your pro tier stages to collapse it's
not going to collapse if you have these
intervals between meals if you don't
turn on mTOR your immunity is not going
to function properly because you
proliferate here your thymus I seen
yours your t-cells your whole immune
system rapamycin is a immune suppression
it's present right now because you're
shutting down mTOR all toxins shut down
in TOR because you can't try transcribe
in the presence of a toxin are you going
to proliferate that and that toxin is
going to invade all the new tissues
you're making so proliferation in mTOR
and amp to areas of the whole thing by
the ways you stimulate mTOR through
mechanical stress when you when you're
when you're consuming damaged proteins
inside your cell mTOR is being signaled
why is that the case well because those
propos amino acids are now available
you have to have that because if you
don't you don't get the innate immunity
an innate stress response can't be
activated gene transcription changes
when you're under stress first of all
because you don't want to make proteins
in a stressful situation
second of all you have to encode other
genes to mount the stress response and
employers doing that because it's
getting the amino acids if you're coming
from the Proteus stasis process so if
they want to chronically turn down the
mTOR they're going to look they're going
to waste away you need a GF one in the
aggressive neurons that are struggling
and stressed you make igf-1 locally not
they're confusing systemic IGF that is
in the serum in the blood right from the
local there's a local signaling and
there's global cycling in some sense and
in the circulation and you're giving
your global signals but in the in the
muscle or in the brain when you activate
when you East when you exercise your
muscles you actually create local igf-1
that doesn't necessarily go out into the
bloodstream I have very low serum igf-1
but I've lost some muscle in it because
I make it locally a dilemma doctor
looked at me and said you can't have
that kind of muscle and have such low I
shave one and I said well I make it
locally
well he's used to seeing national
wrestlers and so forth it was still
enough on insulin for such things right
it's kind of like all the hipsters in
San Francisco or they say think globally
buy locally we'll say you're thinking
globally and making your IGF think I
make it locally but you know what a
muscle contraction will will turn on a
KT and so you're not coming through the
insulin pathway but the second half of
it you're rescuing a katie is a survival
hormone survival in protein
they're thinking about the insulin
pathway exclusively but you've got other
factors down there there's a wonderful
work done by Japanese isomer Roja
akasaki and others who show that if you
can over express a Katy in the muscle
this that's protein kinase be also or
whatever it is and it will heal your
liver so exercise your muscles and heal
your liver and how do you do that you
express a KT and the fast twitch muscle
fibers so in those studies were these
researchers using a high intensity
weight lifting protocol no there is
merely engineering the genes in the in a
mouse to overexpress KT and the fast
twitch fibers profoundly effective
profoundly effective you can't read that
our study and is serious studies my
viscera tomorrow and you can't read that
without saying I want all the fast
twitch fibers I can have if they're not
only disposing glucose they're taking
the glucose disposal burden off the
liver right and off the brain so these
insulin like peptides that are signaling
in the brain too often you're you're
turning turning on down because of the
you're taking good glucose disposal
burden off the other cells and yeah and
so therefore you're reducing insulin
signaling in those cells and it turns
out that when you contract muscle you
make this for B EPE or something like
that which interrupts transcription
what you want to do is you want to have
you don't want to be transcribing new
proteins in your brain when it's not
time to do so you want to be improving
the quality of the neurons so if you if
you exercise you reduce transcription in
other cells because this particular
protein that binds to mTOR and keeps it
from initiating transcription the things
that mTOR does emptor is overrated
anyway it's um it's the survivors ohm
that really matters
please say more good would tell us more
about the ribosomes
well the ribosomes let's say yep you
could make it as start start at the
basics yeah okay well and I could blame
that on my audience and say for those
who don't know but like I would actually
like to educate myself well when you're
going to make a new protein the
messenger RNA comes out it's string the
ribosome is a little bead light
structure that runs across the string
and it's charged with amino acids it
reads the signals on the messenger RNA
and it's transcribes these long strings
of proteins then they go off and they go
through them and then they're folded in
what-have-you
it's actually like a universal turing
machine remember talent Alan Turing said
you can you can make any computer if you
just have a read/write head and a tape
that's what the ribosome is it's the
read/write head that runs along the tape
and makes proteins my neighborhood you
see I was the world's leading expert on
ribosomes god is so complicated it gives
you a headache every time I talked to
him so I finally came up with this idea
well it's a turd a universal Turing
machine it's going across the three tape
is the messenger RNA the right tape is
the protein that is made is but it by
the ribosome
well the ribosome
being very complicated it's very
adaptive you know what what are transfer
bribes so foxy will change the
transcription factors so therefore
change that as messenger RNA and the
ribosome will run across there and
between those two they're like any
universal computer is inherent in what
they can do so you change the
transcription factor you wrinkled up the
DNA a little bit and expose other areas
for transcription and the ribosome is
what is the coating factor that handles
the integrated stress response
approaching transcription changes toward
make the instead of making new proteins
you're making these stress responsive
factors and that's it that's that's
integral to to the survival process that
happens in in response to resistance
training or yes got it yes it does
you'll make FOXO you alter the
transcription of your DNA will make new
messenger RNA and the ribosome if it's
set sense of stress in the cell it'll
begin transcribing these protective
factors instead of like making all in
protein so it will switch to the Andrew
Dillon is a wonderful paper element his
group was taken me where is he been or
is this T Berkeley
oh that's Berkeley man I'm my backyard
he's right up there in Bay Area you may
be as you see sense he has he has a
quantitative biology group there and so
in doing that then in shifting the
transcription to what you were just
describing to you yes survival gentle
horse or stress response stress response
factors we're bolstering that renewal
program yes the failure of which is
complicated for what we call aging
that's precisely right yeah your
immunity is brought up also goodness
everybody everybody who does anything in
aging these days just finally agree it's
a stress response that that's what keeps
you about that that may change the cells
protects them and hormesis is like the
one if they want to leave it on all the
time yeah but they would exhaust you you
can't you can't be poised for every
possible kind of damage wherever the
blood the world's full of
maybe trillions of different kinds of
damage that can happen to you and you
can't have a precisely tuned damage
response to each threat they have to be
generalized
and their generalized through certain
transcription factors and through the
way the frybo zone makes proteins so
these generalized stress responses they
can run across the immune system they
run across the stem cell system
they run across the protein synthesis
across the ribosome all these pathways
intersect and every one of them encodes
some kind of stress response so
protective pathway that's responding to
a toxin rapamycin to bacteria
and the thing you don't want to have
happen is when a bacteria is in there
you don't want to be transcribing
proteins of the bacteria we'll get into
that you'll be making proteins for the
bacteria
so you've got to be able to shut down
transcription at the right time but if
you can't shut down transcription or
mTOR completely because then you can't
make the defensive factors that are
required and if this is where these
micro RNAs seem to come in
are you interested or not interested in
say intermittent use of something like
rapamycin design do you find that is
that just trying to make a deal with the
devil is that are there too many
unknowns or something like that
interesting to you to me I I don't it's
a deal with the devil
okay I haven't even had a cold in 40
years so I'm not going to mess with my
own you exist
so aside from the the let's say the way
that you eat and the spacing of your
meals that we discussed and the
resistance training what other factors
or behaviors interventions do you think
have contributed to not being sick for
decades stay away from kill people okay
we're people but I couldn't when I was
teaching University I had a class with
400 people in and half of them has just
gotten back from China and were coughing
and sneezing and so forth I was sort of
the universal substitute teacher because
everyone else got sick and they knew art
wouldn't be sick they call me up to go
teach their classes it's spooky in a way
it's a D it's just picking you're
picking your parents wisely or is it is
there is there more are there other
factors there are there are other
factors like you expose yourself to some
cold you stress your muscle you you get
plenty of good sleep very important
you've got it and you kind of have these
[Music]
so mTOR windows during your sleep you
got it you've got to live in one window
of the other there's a growth repair
window it saloon window and there's the
Fox though window
insolent or versus Fox oh that's how I
see and I'm going from one window the of
it as a cancel boxer Ethel oxo yes a
fork head box proteins therefore human
versions so important cognitive function
when starving fox allah makes you want
to move so the fox a window for you then
would be part of good sleep which is why
you're not going to eat within four or
five hours right I'm going to bed you're
going to you're going to spend the first
window of sleep sort of rebuilding
tissues second window of sleep you're
into the start start fossil mode and
you're also altering your synapses
there's an interesting new genes called
Homer it counts you floods into your
brain yet excitatory fact signaling just
depressed
not much glutamate so Homer cutscene and
it shrinks your synapses it's very
verbally named that's hilarious it is
hilarious as proportional shrinking in
other words you're going to say ten
percent each sentence is going to shrink
by 10 percent the bigger synapses are
the most active ones that's where
post-traumatic stress lives so if you
can shrink those they have to be stable
but if you keep rehearsing that same
synapse constantly is going to grow and
strengthen people Hoover berate thoughts
in their mind or ruminate a lot they
could they get depressed because of
those circuits according to jail Adelman
that's neural Darwinism
this rules Arwen as a neural Darwinism
Darwin
there's Darwinian competition going on
inside your cells everywhere so for
those people listening who do ruminate
and perseverate that's another good word
constantly and get depressed what what
advice might you give them starve and
exercise starved exercise now the eye
you know you might get more to say
solidly please continue well starve
starve and exercise but to something
that's totally different so that you you
set up neural circuits that compete with
the ones that are ruminating and
building and strengthening you in your
brain but the starvation part of it is
to eat up some dentists some of these
dysfunctional synapses by saying is for
every damaged molecule there's a damaged
thought
and your depressed brain or a brain that
is on it has post-traumatic stress those
are injured neurons inside the brain and
you just need to get rid of the
dysfunctional molecules that are causing
those neurons to malfunction so I guess
yeah I mean of course I mean it seems
self-evident those people it goes it
goes both ways right enemy for every
damaged thought there's a damaged
molecule so if you're thinking about it
rather than trying to think your way out
of that problem heal the brain first
heal first heal the brain and you heal
it with neurotropic factors out the
outside new thoughts new new patterns of
behavior how would you feel instead
silly that to ask but how would you feed
those new thoughts you know if a kfl
loved one of yours was was getting
depressed and exhibiting these symptoms
what would you prescribe to them well
you know when my first wine prism was
declining
from all host of other things I take it
walking as much as I could I would tell
her bad jokes change their surroundings
you know the typical things that people
have to do being outside is enormous ly
affected their stimuli you can't even
relate to you but you perceive them and
you're unconscious praying is what's
going to heal you first and the
unconscious brain is more healthy when
it's exposed to nature and happy people
and children and dogs are did our for
our friend of all I think it's I'm
thinking I'm getting this attribution
right but he said the first the first
first rule of conflict resolution or
minimizing conflict is to not spend a
lot of time around people who are
constantly in conflict but that was I
thought that was a good rule a lot of
politics is exposed to severe so turnoff
fingers you amaze you you mentioned in
passing cold exposure so this is
something that I've found to be
tremendously effective in mood elevation
and among other things but how do you
expose yourself to cold
well I walk the dogs early in the
morning with almost no jacket or
anything just just go out and get nice
and chilly with them cold showers and
cool just be aware where do you live now
oh southern Utah so it's not as no good
no longer UCLA or ask I don't know no
it's not but even even if you live in a
desert like climate is cool in the
morning
sure quite cool in the morning I keep
the pool cold I don't hate the pool much
and I take cool showers I don't try to
shock myself what so you then oh this is
may seem like a non-sequitur which is
most of my brain but we were talking
about what you taught nothing as it
related to exercise are there anything
any any particular things that you've
learned from him or and that could be
what you used his book to illustrate in
your class or anything else oh sure I
mean he first of all he is a marvelous
writer it
tells stories in a way I could never
tell Fat Tony yeah Tony right he creates
marvelous characters that embody the
kind of thing he wants to ridicule or
our core our power point out is you know
savvy he likes street smarts like I do
we both like math smarts too
I mean actual he went to the Courant
Institute you know he's a very well
trained mathematician far better than I
I guess we all need a Black Swan hunting
devices it is something in some sense
like I tried to create a financial
device crook for a partner who is too
dumb to be all good take this anywhere
but I figured out ways of using kurtosis
to finance pharmaceuticals and could you
define kurtosis please and spell that
it's a measure of the odd shape of the
distribution it's high VP and skew off
to the right or something it looks very
non normal resemble a bell curve
no but it's a thing of beauty because
it's more life lives that's where life
is in that kind of the fractional type
distributions is like a Pareto
distribution and then they drop down at
the at the minimum um see we build that
for pharmaceutical development is that
yes yes I had because if the boot the
last talk I gave at Harvard was between
what compared in the movies to
pharmaceuticals and it turned out that
they were the same kind of statistical
distributions look Ratanak it sounds
like something you should gargle for
it's actually a thing of beauty it's a
skewed and biased to the right and with
a very long heavy tail heavy tail being
because every tail is long in a sense
but they become very thin it has a lot
of probability out there that's that's
the truth power line distribution Pareto
distribution and so forth so it turns
out pharmaceuticals that way because a
few pharmaceutical cell billions and
billions and billions of dollars work
for like 12 billion dollars a year most
pharmaceutical cell about half a million
mm
billion maybe at most so it's the big
outliers that dominate the industry in
revenues so using that skew you can
design a swamp-like instrument that uses
the upper tail to pay the lower tail and
it if you divide it correctly
you have a very favorable kind of gamble
so his Blackwood would Talib's Black
Swan hunting device then be derivatives
training would that be how or would it
be something well listen to me actually
you're the one to talk about that
because you're the guys who's found all
the black swans with the startups yeah I
mean that's that's certainly but well I
mean the way of we're going to maybe get
off the reservation here for a second
but the way I've thought about that is
because I do not have the mathematical
or modeling background of you nor Nassim
or anybody else I it's not a funny story
it's kind of a tragic story but
tenth-grade my brother and i had two
different math teachers i had a math
teacher who was very caustic really had
a chip on her shoulder and berated
students
sounds like Nicene well he had a
different response I think nothing is
more pugnacious than I am so he so so he
showed his teacher I decided to choose
my college based on lack of math
requirement my brother had a fantastic
teacher he knows a PhD in statistics
oh isn't that something yeah there's
this an extreme event right there yeah a
little mall event but it really changed
course yeah it it completely changed the
course of my life and therefore I eat in
my case when I remember having a
conversation with 8:00
my manager and they're there plenty of
bad hedge fund managers out there and I
don't think they go by that name anymore
but there are some very very brilliant
people in the game and I spoke with one
and I'm not going to get this totally
right and and do justice but he said you
can have a there are a number of
different advantages you can have and
you need to have at least one you said
you can have an informational advantage
you can have an analytical advantage you
could have a say behavioral advantage
and meaning if you're someone like a
there are plenty of people who try to
imitate say Buffett but they emotionally
react to the market differently then
about your era monger and so on and so
forth there many of these and what I
realized was given my sets of strengths
and weaknesses where I could capitalize
was in the informational advantage by
placing myself in the center of the
switch box in Silicon Valley so that
became my way of hunting for black swans
fantastic if you can handle the
information loan just coming through
there well you know what what was so odd
about it in a sense or counterintuitive
for a lot of people I describe this too
and nothing's actually informed my
thinking a lot on this because and I'm
again not going to do his description
justice but thinking in a barbell
fashion where I have the vast majority
of my assets and investments are cash or
cash like equivalents and then I have
this smaller portion that is speculative
but very asymmetrical returns if I can
think through basic portfolio management
properly and when I realized for myself
is that I have an emotional disadvantage
when it comes to publicly traded
anything I respond very poorly to a
compulsively despite knowing it's not my
best interest looking at watching people
freak out and the sky is falling and
then I become Chicken Little and I sell
at the worst time so what's what's
fantastic about startups for me and I do
not recommend this to anyone who does
not have a significant advantage as I
did that I would do all of my homework
make a decision invest and then I
couldn't sell it was a liquid and that
turned out to be a very good thing
I was locked in out on 10 you know had
to do all of my homework on the front
end yeah and then there was no
ticker-tape for me to watch no charts
for me to watch really
and it's just worked out fantastically I
had a professor who was long and sugar
when the Castro Revolution is he finally
said I can't take it anymore I gotta I
gotta clear my position oh man it's
gonna be working ya know it's I'm really
really really bad at anything that I can
watch moving up and down so I need to
address that and my own place in a lot
of ways but so we're talking about well
for instance I mean talking about the
the sugar position and I remember asking
a friend of mine his very good investor
about liquidating certain positions or
not and he said well I think you should
just look as I was asking him for
certain dollar ranges how he runs the
math and he said I just sell down to
sleep a sleep at night level that's
exactly so selling to sleep at night
level and you mentioned getting good
sleep what is what are things that you
do or don't do to help ensure good sleep
for yourself well I here's probably the
only supplement I take I do take some
melatonin melatonin and do you take that
on a daily basis sometimes but nothing
fighting and bring any with me on the
far right so forth I don't do anything
regularly but so melatonin is much more
than just a sleep aid it's so it's found
in plants it's a resistance of stress
resistant protein it does have powerful
antioxidant properties but you need
oxidants to ox ox ox ative molecules or
signaling molecules as well but you need
a proper balance of signaling verses
chronically signaling oxygen molecules
but there's some other direct itself I
think it stimulates the tava G in the
brain or some of these more fundamental
processes that maybe it brings out Homer
out of his cave
I know you you how how do you think
about dosing is this psycho one
milligram a 3 milligram give an idea um
5 5 sometimes 10 Wow okay so that's a
dose that I would use if I flew to Hong
Kong to correct my sleep cycle sure you
would yeah you would and it would work
but I don't do it for sleep I do it for
other other things it does got it and do
you worry at all and this this has been
certain things you you are not terribly
interested in like rapamycin do you
worry at all and this is the question
that came to mind I haven't asked him
directly but Dom we know Dominic
D'Agostino also uses Melton on a very
very regular basis do you worry about
any type of negative feedback loop or
tolerance development or side-effects
from chronic use of Melton a lot of
people do and I maybe I did at one time
when I didn't know enough about it but
actually it's not
you're not going to shut down the
biennial gland from making melatonin
because you because you're not really
stimulating it to make it in the first
place you're not you're thinking in
terms of the whole homeostatic balance
no its own I'm not I'm thinking about it
as a surge that's bringing a protective
pathways I think it'd be in a completely
different way and I don't even take it
to sleep I take it to brawl yeah yeah
keep my brain to some and Homer yeah so
is actually everything I think of I
think in terms of those protective
pathways immunity restore restoration
pathways the whole whole knowledge that
I thought I had before is sort of out
the window and you think in terms of you
smell like you know what pathways let's
I'd like to explore that a little bit
and this is going to I'm sure uncover a
fairly deep level of ignorance on my
part but if we're thinking about I know
very little about melatonin but I have
taken in the past if if we're looking at
say the how does production wealth and
trying to frame this
if I think of the HP ta like that I
hypothalamus pituitary testosterone axis
and the ways that can be disrupted if
you supplement with a fist Ostrow nor
luteinizing hormone which I guess would
be HCG when you're injecting it or
taking some other form even if state
testosterone or growth hormone for that
matter or released in surges it's not
not continually much like melatonin
why wouldn't regular consumption of
melatonin cause some type of malfunction
I just don't know if it's one thing in a
large stream of of other elements that I
don't know about I don't have the answer
to that either it so first of all you're
positive if there's a feedback like no I
am and I don't let you know I'm not I'm
not even positive I'm just asking
yeah so I would I wouldn't necessarily
pause it that feedback pathway to begin
with because I don't think it's a
homeostatic balance there I don't think
it's that the body attempts to maintain
pulses are or a balance of melatonin I
think it's you actually make it during
the day too it's not it's not the sleep
hormone it's a defensive hormone I mean
it's in plants plant zone don't have to
get your rest or sleep they're not
moving around all they're much it's it's
an ancient ancient hormone it's
evolutionarily conserved across almost
all species and I used to know a lot
about it I haven't thought about it in a
while so you caught me short of
knowledge
well ah maybe this is a good place to
talk about the the limits of human
knowledge and a person's in reading the
Black Swan nothing talks about
epistemological arrogance fair amount
and and I think just to give people an
example of that just to bring it down to
eat more easily interested level I'm a
very good friend of mine well a lot of
doctor says any good doctor will
generally say 50% of what we know is
wrong we just don't know which 50
yeah is it so very true how do you how
do you think about human knowledge what
we can know versus what we can't know
and then this very broad question but
that was one of the topics that they've
all recommended bouncing around in this
conversation so I end it this is
something that has caused me to go from
taking a lot of supplements to taking
fewer supplements for instance because
there's so many historical case studies
of carrots are good for us we think they
improve eyesight we attributed to
beta-carotene and we start taking mega
doses of beta-carotene oops
turns out there's a lot more to the
story now we've created all these
unanticipated side-effects yeah I think
even if you look at a static diagram of
something like the mTOR pathway like
gosh it's so complicated and then you
realize at all they all have to be in
the right sequence to these molecules
have to move at the right speed and have
the right doses and so forth you never
be able to figure that out so what you
have to do is you have to be an
experimentalist maybe on yourself like
you and I do
maybe when you're your child or in
college about Molly
I actually had the experiment on my
child I didn't like to but I had to
because the doctors were killing him so
I don't want to get into that too much
but you have to be willing to test
hypotheses why not just admit that
nature knows a lot more than we do and
try to live a simple clean decent life
any good food and go hungry now and then
mimic mimic those patterns there's an
air correction mechanism inside each one
of us if you err in terms of
example you make you make some bad cells
some bad proteins or some of your stem
cells go bad
nature's down there cleaning it up
because the other stem cell will kill it
it will consume it or shove it out of
the niche just like Eagles get showed
out of you know nestlings get shoved out
of the niche there's competition going
on inside your body constantly and if
you use competition to weed out the weak
and the faulty and let the strong
survive so you really your ideas are
competing also everything is a question
of variety pruning competition pruning
things like I said God said I got these
different species I'll send that let's
let's see which one which one is best
which one gets through the Ice Age
that's how you do it and your body is
constantly pruning your thoughts your
motivations your rewards
and sleep is the way you clean all that
up so I I want to shift gears a little
bit I'll just ask some of what my
audience knows is rapid-fire questions
your answers don't need to be rapid but
this is we come to sort of the the tail
end of our chat what books have you
gifted most to other people or
recommended most to other people there
any particular that come to mind well I
mean I gave all my library books to the
local college library and they were full
of books not philosophy I've thrown my
philosophy books away
why then and the pointless empty empty
questions for the most part they're not
testable hypotheses got it yeah I've
been generous with my thoughts more than
I have with my my books in the sense
I've gifted the bulk of my knowledge
that I developed on my webpage and in my
first essay on evolutionary fitness soon
acknowledged I put out there about the
paleo lifestyle I think it was a real
gift I gave to a lot of people who
carried on and then developed further
and I wasn't the originator but Lauren
and I were both sort of thinking about
law recording and I were thinking about
these things simultaneously
I kept telling him don't John Lauren no
joke yeah I think he probably still
doesn t I'm sure he's quite healthy
still on so that's that's that's the
primary gift in I gifted many
dissertation topics to graduate students
I ran more graduate students at the
universities where I work and anyone
else in the department the students were
drawn drawing to me but my ideas were
kind of complicated in this so there was
not necessarily a good dissertation
there in the usual sense okay
good news you have me as an advisor bad
news it's a hard topic yeah are there
any particular books that have very
heavily influenced you or books it what
what are books that you've read if any
come to mind I actually read the journal
literature
I don't read very many books hang on
scientific literature mm-hmm where do
you go hunting for literature and how do
you decide what to read um I choose the
topic and I looked very broadly at the
topic from a mathematical point of view
from biological point of view which is
what while my reading now I must have
the my bibliography is getting close to
8,000 entries in a Miss Asian literature
and what a goofy literature summer
videos
you know I mean it's there's some
fantastic articles there and there's
just a lot of fluff and redoing and
reviews and and sometimes the article
will the abstract of the article won't
be as long as a listing of authors it's
really weird to say a party party review
yeah okay they figured out how to get
citations yeah economists never we
should we we don't coffee with a much
yeah maybe one or two co-authors at
the most
well I mean if Cubans respond to
incentives right get it it'll be
I is that mostly PubMed what sources do
you like to to use are you subscribing
to particular journals themselves
I still have professor Meredith so I
have access to what I like there's no
collaborations yeah yeah not bad don't
get into reading about diets it's an
endless literature and it's pretty lousy
what are in the in the fields or field
of aging longevity although I feel like
that words kind of tainted but yeah life
extension I had that one - I don't even
know what's call it but what are the
current wild goose chases in your
opinion or areas that are some potential
dead ends or things that are just
getting way overblown in your mind
I do think these attempts to manipulate
mTOR are are kind of pointing this you
chronically shut down am drawer you're
going to shrink to nothing you're not
going to make new proteins in its
windows you've got to have you got to
have these switches the most fruitful
papers that I read talk about a pathway
that crosses another one and they have
switches your turn them on and off you
age in this window you don't age in that
window is one way to look at it good
yeah yeah that's a helpful would look at
yeah so you just want to have but not 80
aging yeah you want to be defending or
renewing but most people in today's life
are renewing on a continuous basis and
so there miss folding proteins and
they're damaging the cells and building
fat in tissues where it doesn't belong
and so forth so I think all these
attempts to stall mTOR are really kind
of weird gives you we want to stall it
if you don't want to over proliferate
but you actually want to be capable of
proliferating when it's essential
because when you want to renew a cell or
P build rebuild tissues you have to be
able to do that body building it the
whole that whole notion of regularity
and chronic are totally wrong and if
you've got to have switches when
knows and you go back and forth you
alternate you gotta be alternating
States is a way to think about things
the problem is some of the people have
looked at for example sympathy Kenyans
work on the worms and so forth the
functional pathway there are lots of
residual pathways from that and there
are Fox for kid box genes that were part
of the development process that are now
resident in the cells that can respond
and defend in the Primmer cell for
example if you work out you accrue you
your trigger fox P and foxy M proteins
in your in your brain well then by
workout you mean sprint or uh resistance
training yeah you can jog if you want to
if you want to you know kill some of
your stem cells with them oh no you you
got to have a right you got to do all of
these things so I think the idea of
switching switches and Windows is going
to come in systemic signaling is the
hottest new thing in in aging research
which makes a lot of sense that is
signaling at a distance
I think the stem cell pathways are going
to turn out to be just crucial and very
very important and again mTOR is sort of
misplace because we got we have so many
sick people in the world it's bad to be
average now in today's world it's really
bad I've never had average-looking
testing you know I'm in my blood work or
anything else and um averages average
dangerous it is I so dangerous reminded
me of one thing that you said in passing
and I want a good unpack it it may not
be a long story but you said I've never
been injured in all these decades of
weight training except for one instance
that I can remember what was the one
instance what happened oh man it was
just
this weird guy in the gym yeah yeah I
was going to say yeah is it old he was a
fireman and he worked out all at the gym
and he used to do these behind-the-neck
presses
oh right with the barbell yeah with a
barbell so he's using some whiteness oh
well then that's nothing I wasn't warmed
up or anything I have done I said well
that's easy and I and I did it and I
pulled a muscle in my neck ain't I heard
for three months what are what are
things that you do to help minimize the
likelihood of injury whether it's some
type of warm-up before you go into your
your your negative work or otherwise
well first thing I don't warm up you
don't want no like Eichmann sir you've
got a filter in and start working out
now when I was you go straight to your
first work set whatever that might be
yeah but it's usually
sort of mild and I mean start with my
so-called famous hierarchical sets a
lightweight 15 reps heavier weight eight
reps a heavier weight yet four reps
you're going right up the fibre
hierarchy slow intermediate fast switch
now you're warm you warm up more more
rapidly if you do something that's
reasonably intense and then the rest of
the workout you're warm
I work out early morning when it's cold
or I used to you and now now that I
don't have a job anymore I'm retired I
work out at 11:00 and every every time I
go there I see the same guy he's an ex
body movement you can tell he looks good
he still pays there for hours and I'm in
and out I don't know who looks better I
think I do but I'm leaner he's a more
bodybuilding looking looking guy and
they don't they don't look good when
they're not flexed they don't look good
let's face it you mean you don't look
like the second trimester abdominal no
no and just for all the bodybuilders in
the audience it's not all of you but
let's be honest if we look at some of
the competitors when they're not flexed
oh oh boy
how long you know is it a boy or a girl
that's right that's exactly right
so I really I'm there for a little
adventure for a little bit of intensity
not to get hurt so if you have long
muscles you do full range of motion
you're not going to get hurt and you're
also generally at least on the on the
negatives following a slow cadence I
mean you're you're you might be raising
it quickly but you're lowering it
entirely under control control entirely
under control but down to a full stretch
right I'm thinking I'm thinking tighten
spring right there's a spring down there
and so even if I'm doing positive
exercises I will lower and I'll come
kinda die do a little not not a bounce
because full stop balances are
destructive but the little stretch
bounce right
if you were to go back to teaching and
you were to teach a freshman
undergraduate or a senior seminar so
it's just 15 to 40 students something
like that and you only add them once a
week let's say let's say I'm once a week
for three hours one semester what would
you what would you teach them the
economics of uncertainty economic test
the last class I developed there at UCI
and I thought they loved they loved the
class economics of extreme events is
really where it was not uncertainty the
way it's taught by utility theory and
all this nice utility maximization and
expected this and expected that it's all
nonsense it would it would be the
economics of extreme events if someone
wanted to since you're probably not
going to teach that class anytime soon
is if somebody wanted to explore that
for themselves how would they self
educate any rekha a nice starting point
so you'd recommend my class notes are
somewhere she's definitely somehow crowd
crowdfund getting them I would diversify
with my movie book what was the title of
that Hollywood Hollywood economics
it covers extreme events fairly barely
thoroughly in fact a lot of students
looked at that I had other by other
readings as well or you could look at
climate science and look at the extreme
climate Theory extremes of climate
planner variation and what happens you
could look at the economics of storms
and and floods floodplain analysis so I
would look at nature if you were to pick
one of Na Siam's books to start with
would you choose fooled by randomness or
would it be one of the other things
students learn more from fooled by
randomness the Black Swan is marvelous
as well skin in the game probably going
to be a terrific book too because he you
got to have skin in the game
and everybody knows that but they always
ignore it
if you want to do a chapter a Chinese
fun you got to put skinny with him yeah
yeah oh yeah
30% yes are you oh they want they want
incentives a lot they won't just cut
your knuckles off it's just is more
today I so the the economics of extreme
events if you could put anything on a
billboard you have a gigantic mill board
you can put a short message a word
couple words sentence whatever to get
out to millions of people what would
that message be or whatever you would
put on the billboard could be anything
well I used to end my my principles of
economics teaching the importance of
freedom in arbitrage arbitrage keeps you
from being stupid
because you compare the price of this
relative to other equivalents are close
substitutes and so forth if you do if
you talk mathematically about pricing
you lose the anchoring from the
arbitrage principle so I always tell
arbitrage arbitrage can you could you
explain that maybe through an example I
just looked at yeah well we'll buy low
in and and sell high but you trade you
have to trade different alternatives for
example make sure of pores a vacuum and
economics of a porous and arbitrage
opportunity arbitrage opportunities get
eliminated
is that okay got to be is that just
efficient run out of here Mario Theory
like it's a sensible way of looking at
efficient markets the best predictor of
tomorrow's price of something is today's
price because that leaves no arbitrage
opportunity right if you knew the price
is going up tomorrow we'd go up today
you know that that kind of thinking you
think about opportunities where you
think in terms of the arbitrage limits
did it there so I tell us our general
equilibrium theory is arbitrage also it
wasn't too successful
it wasn't it wasn't appreciated but
sound this is how my Linville taught
general equilibrium theory also knows
it's the presence of arbitrage so would
you just put understand arbitrage would
that be the message the veal pork yeah
um know that it would be freedom counts
freedom counts now freedom manners and
is that mostly in reference to markets
or is it freedom of contract freedom of
arbitrage freedom venturing freedom of
exit people don't have to be forced to
do things they can exit I can they can
participate freedom counts yeah like
that uh egg what workouts to lift heavy
things and everything's freedom counts
well art we could talk for hours and
hours and hours and and then we're going
to go go probably grab a bite to eat at
some point after this but is there is
there anything and I'm going to ask you
after this where people can learn more
about you what you would like them to
check out and certainly that'll all go
in the show notes but is there any are a
parting words or suggestions or asks of
my audience something I should test
something you should consider anything
that you'd like people to get ready for
mine for my book when it comes out on
I'm aging as a feel this full of a lot
of charlatans there's some good science
and there's some there's no such thing
as successful aging because aging is
damaged so you can't be successful if
you're being damaged and do you have a
give a set timeline for that or a titles
people should look out for or should we
just say prime yourselves it's coming
and we will let you know when it comes
out yeah just check my facebook
page that's that's my I've given up my
blog it wasn't worth the time and effort
I did help a lot of people but not past
that now I taking up this as it really
is a scientific quest because one like I
said I'm experienced coming out coming
up on aging on 80 is
you start thinking about you know when
you approach middle-age you start
thinking about these things when you
wait so you're planning you're planning
your next 80 if it's the possibility the
technology is coming and it is there
right now inside each person is the
protein quality control cell quality
control
don't lose cells maintain them starve
them within a while that's good for them
so it's the technology I am applying the
technology and I think I'm doing pretty
well at it so far I do plan to live
another 40 60 years I think you're doing
pretty well and your arms are bulging
out of your shirt which is long sleeved
so I think things are going well well
art thank you so much for the time I
really appreciate it and this is this
has been a lot of fun and for everybody
listening as always you can find links
to everything that we've discussed to
our Facebook page and more at Facebook's
not Facebook let's try that again at
4-hour workweek comm forward slash
podcast or at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast they both go to the same place
and you'll find show notes for this
episode and every other episode and
until next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is by bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday does that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird that have somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's for
our workweek calm all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up I
hope you enjoyed this episode is brought
to you by audible which I have used for
many many years I absolutely love
audiobooks and they are one of my
favorite ways to past the time when I
travel I'm on the road all the time and
audible allows me to consume many more
books than I possibly could otherwise I
have two audio books to recommend right
off the bat the first is perhaps my
favorite audio book of all time and it's
the only audio book I've wanted to
listen to twice in a row the graveyard
book by Neil Gaiman it's amazing and you
will thank there are a few different
versions
I like the version that Neal narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Rolf Potts P o T TS which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what would later
become the 4-hour workweek so go to
audible.com for word slash Tim and you
can choose one of these two books or any
of many many other options back of books
magazines and much more as a listener of
the Tim Ferriss show you can also access
a free 30-day trial just go to
audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it
so turn your travel or your commute into
something more with a free trial at
audible.com forward slash Tim to start
now and get your free 30-day trial this
podcast is brought to you by 4 Sigma
tech I reached out to these Finnish
folks young entrepreneurs very talented
after a Acrobat introduced me to one of
their products which is mushroom coffee
this specific one includes chaga and
lion's mane and it knocked my socks off
I highly recommend if you try it you
start with half a packet it's very
strong and lights you up like a
Christmas tree in the best way possible
people are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer I try to force
this on all of my houseguests it is a
hell of a thing if I have employees or
people come over who are working on
projects with me I always try to feed it
to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect
it's a lot we're out of them the first
time I mentioned this product and for
sig Matic on the podcast their products
sold out in less than a week so you may
want to check them out soon if you're
listening to this and the coffee tastes
like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you get in a regular
cup of coffee I don't get any jitters
acid reflux or any stomach burn any of
that it's very unusual and very very
cool so if you don't like caffeine they
also offer very strong but capping free
mushroom elixirs which I will sometimes
have in the evening I find chaga
specifically to be very very grounding
and earthy so that is another option and
I have a cupboard full of their products
at the moment which is right around the
corner in my kitchen you can try
something you can try a sample pack
which is great also right now by going
to four sig Matic dot-com forward slash
Tim that's for sig Matic fo you are SI
GM apic comm forward slash Tim and use
the code tim TI m to get 20% off of your
first order and they're not that
expensive anyway if you are in the
experimental mindset I do not think
you'll be disappointed
so trauma
[Applause]